welcome back to facebook.censored from
New York City tonight exclusive
interview with a man who almost changed
the world and who some people believe
should still be locked up in prison for
the rest of his life
it was 30 seconds and Six Bullets that
changed American history
March the 30th 1981 a man opened fire on
President Reagan as he left the Hilton
Hotel in Washington DC a bullet
ricocheted off the president's limo and
lodged within an inch of his heart
almost killing him
Reagan's press secretary James Brady was
paralyzed for Life the gunman was John
Hinckley Jr the mentally ill 25 year old
was obsessed with a young actress Jody
Foster
pressed and delusional he thought
killing the president could win her
affections
after 12 days in hospital Reagan made a
full recovery serving two terms as one
of America's most popular ever
presidents Hinckley was found not guilty
of attempting Murder By reason of
insanity but spent 30 years in
psychiatric care and another 10 under
close supervision this year he was
granted full freedom the whole world
knows his name and what he did tonight
they'll hear his story and it's
uncensored
well John Hinckley Jr rejoins me now
John Hinckley uh thank you again for
coming on the program I appreciate it
and you said that you want to change I
guess people's perceptions if they have
a negative view of you just to take you
back to that day when Ronald Reagan was
was shot by you along with three other
people what Memories do you have of your
actions that day
foreign
I just remember
I was at a hotel in Washington DC
and I I happened to have the uh the
newspaper
before me I saw the president's schedule
for that day
and uh that's where I how I knew where
he would be that day
and I think I went I think I went and
got some breakfast
and then I went up to the hotel
and in those days it was easy to get
pretty close to a president of course
that's all changed now but
back then it was pretty easy to get
close to the president and unfortunately
I was able to go through with the crime
do you remember actually firing your gun
not not anymore no I don't
your motivation at the time albeit you
it was decided that you were suffering
from severe mental illness so not
responsible directly for your actions
was that you'd become obsessed with the
movie star Jody Foster after watching
the movie Taxi Driver in which a
character does actually plot to
assassinate a presidential candidate
do you recall any of your feelings about
Jody Foster that would lead you you know
I think you were trying to impress her
by doing this but do you recall that the
build up of feelings that you had about
her that would lead you to do such an
extreme Act
well I mean I had first seen her I
believe in the movie Taxi Driver and
that was in 1976 I believe
and this Obsession that I developed this
kind of built over the next several
years
to where in 1980
she went off to college at Yale
University
and I went to Yale to uh follow her
and try and find her
and uh that just didn't turn out that
turned out badly
and so uh I just kind of my thinking
just
went very uh negative and that's why
when ahead was the shooting
what do you feel about Jody Foster today
well I have very kind feelings for her
you know I'm so I've I've apologized to
her for bringing into all of this
and I just wish her a very good life
there will be a lot of people uh John
Hinckley who will have just heard the
last few minutes of what you've been
saying and felt a chill got their spine
that somebody could stalk a major
celebrity for several years I think at
one stage you also stalked Jimmy Carter
before you fired these fateful shots at
President Reagan we're faithful for at
least one of the people you shot James
Brady who ended up dying many years
later from his injuries but they'll feel
a chill that must find thinking somebody
that could do all this have such a
dangerous Obsession that led to such
dangerous stalking and then the ultimate
Act of danger of trying to assassinate a
an American president that that person
should never be released and there's
been a lot of anger since you were given
full Freedom
um what do you feel about that I mean do
you feel yourself that you it is right
that you should be released I mean I'll
give you an analogy Mark Chapman shot
John Lennon I think a year before you he
remains incarcerated with no real sign
of of being released at all but that's
because he killed Lenin but at least one
of the people you shot died as a result
of those injuries years later do you see
a distinction between the two of you
between you and Mark Chapman you think
it's right you're free
as
I see a big distinction because
Mark Chapman was found guilty and he
he's been in prison all these years I
was never in prison peers I was in a
hospital
for 35 years receiving treatment
I was found not guilty by reason of
insanity and sent to Saint Elizabeth's
and I received treatment all these years
in
my my family stood behind me and I had a
great lawyer Barry Levine
and you know I feel like my my release
was very Justified
but do you understand why many people
feel angry because if you've been
successful in your mission to which is
premeditated you've already said that if
you succeeded in killing Reagan you
would have changed the course of
American history of global history
turned out to be a very popular
successful president but you would have
snuffed him out of the very start of his
presidency do you understand why some
people feel enraged that you've been let
out and allowed to lead a completely
free life
I underst I can understand that yes I
just hope that they would also
understand that I'm a completely changed
man now
uh I just it's it's been so long ago
that that happened and a lot of good
things have happened to me since then
to where uh I just hope people who have
negative feelings about me can
take another look at me and listen to my
music I tell people if they want to get
to know me to listen to my songs
because uh all of my songs are uplifting
about overcoming hard times
and then get to know me pretty well by
listening to my music I mean you've
actually you've been trying to perform
live at music venues but they've all
been canceled because of outcries and
threats to people's lives and security
issues and so on it may be impossible
for you to pursue this kind of career
publicly by performing which again it
suggests there's a lot of anger out
there and concern that people may take
the law into their own hands because
they feel that Justice wasn't properly
served
well I keep trying I mean you're right
I've had about five or six venues cancel
on me because after the concert gets
announced they start receiving negative
backlash
and they back out of the concert that's
happening about six times
so I'm I'm gonna keep trying but um
hoping for a venue that'll Stand By Me
just to be clear about one thing you you
did want to kill President Reagan right
well I suppose they'll suppose so back
then I did
[Music]
um
I'm just so glad I didn't I did not
succeed
and obviously James Brady as I say died
many years later from the injuries from
you shooting him it was paralyzed for
life it ruined his life what are your
feelings towards the Brady family who I
mean at the very least I would imagine
are pretty concerned about the fact
you've been let out
well I just wish them all the good
health in life and I I wish they could
just forgive me that I wouldn't blame if
wouldn't blame them if they don't
forgive me but I wish they could
because I'm sure sorry for what I did
have you ever heard from any of the
Reagan family directly
no I'm not and I'll see all these years
I've had a court ordered to where I
could not communicate with the victims
of the shooting or the or their families
but even now that I don't have that
court order anymore I don't I don't
think they want to hear from me to be
honest
so I'm just going to try and you know
let them have their
distance okay I'm gonna take a short
break John Hinckley Jr will come back
with more my exclusive interview with
the man who tried to kill a president
welcome back to Piers Morgan on censored
from New York City more from my
exclusive interview with the man that
tried to kill President Reagan John
Hinckley Jr rejoins me now John Hinckley
uh do you still take medication for the
severe mental illness that you had
I do peers I take two psychiatric
medicines
and what impact do you believe the
medicine has had on you
antidepressant and you know it just
prevents me from getting depression and
um I think they are effective and I have
no problem taking the medicines
when was the the moment for you that you
became aware of the enormity of what
you'd done
I think after I got hospitalized maybe
about
six months later
um
it all kind of just dawned on me that
what I did was so terrible
and I think that was the start of my
recovery
I mean if you'd actually killed Reagan
obviously you would never have been
released from prison
have you thought about that
that's probably true
it changed security around presidents
irrevocably you know I've been around a
few uh of the more recent presidents and
the security around them is
extraordinary as a result of what
happened that day what do you feel about
about guns you obviously used a gun to
cause Carnage that day nearly to kill
the president it's an ongoing debate an
issue in America do you feel there
should be as there are now many more
restrictions around the president do you
feel there should be more restrictions
around guns themselves for The Wider
populace
I do
I do I think I think there are too many
guns in America to be honest
uh it's just kind of a very volatile
time right now
and it's it's not good that there's so
many guns in America
when you did what you did uh John
Hinckley what was your family reaction
to it did they stand by you did they
disown you
my family stood by me from the first
moment up till their until their my
parents deaths they stood by me all the
way
your father and my brother and sister
still Stand By Me your father I think
blamed himself for what had happened why
would he do that
I don't know but I certainly didn't
blame him I think he said that on the
stand during my trial
but I never had that feeling of blaming
him
when you look back at your life what do
you think prompted
such a severe mental illness that you
would commit the crime you committed
I I you know I had a good upbringing
with my family so I think it was more of
a chemical imbalance
in my brain that caused the depression
which which led me to get
um estranged from my family that was
another thing that happened that was too
bad was
I got you know
um isolated from my family and that was
that was a took it took a bad turn after
that
many Americans I think believe in second
chances for people in in Rehabilitation
uh some don't but many do
but when you do you tell people who you
are because your name is very
distinctive and if they if they work out
who you are how do they react
well here in Williamsburg you know
people are very nice to me and that's
the main reason I live here is
I get along fine here
uh my name is very well known
but I've always said that you know my
Persona is not that well known so I can
I can go to the grocery store
or to other places and I don't get
bothered it's just it's just that my
name is so well known
there will be some people who don't
think we should even do this interview
who don't think you should be given the
oxygen of publicity what do you say to
them
well I'm glad you did because I'm trying
to get out the message that I'm a
changed person and if if all these years
people have had a negative image of me I
hope they can see me now as somebody who
has changed a lot
I suppose you'll be I thank you for
giving me that opportunity right I mean
the obvious question I guess I would
throw back at you for that is how can we
be sure you've changed you know as you
say you're still on medication to
control your illness what you did wasn't
just a one-off spontaneous moment of
violence it was after several years of
very Sinister stalking of a movie star
stalking of another man who became
president and then ultimately
shooting Ronald Reagan you know there
will be people watching this going well
he may say he's changed how can we be
sure
well I would say that I have a really
good track record you know I wasn't just
released one day from the hospital I got
released over a number of years my judge
you know gave me freedom and incremental
steps to see how I would do I've always
done well with the freedoms that he gave
me
and I've proven myself to be you know a
very peaceful person now
and that's how I plan to live my life
do you want forgiveness is that is that
something you seek and if so who from
sure I think everybody wants forgiveness
if they if they need it and just from
the public at Large
and from the Reagan family and from
Jodie Foster from the family of James
certainly and the others the victims yes
the victim's family I wish I wish so
much they could forgive me
but as I said earlier I wouldn't I
wouldn't I wouldn't uh blame them if
they didn't forgive me but I wish they
would
in the case of James Brady of course as
I say he died from the uh wounds that he
suffered
um and it was designated homicide by the
coroner because of the year in a day
rule which existed at the time you could
not be tried for murder but do you
accept now that because you fired the
gun at James Brady that caused his
catastrophic injuries and subsequent
death that you were guilty of his murder
well I wouldn't say that I mean I
certainly caused him to have devastating
injuries but
um I believe he lived on for another 30
something years
um so I can't really see I'm the cause
of the murder
I mean it was ruled to homicide by the
coroner and he he suffered horrendously
from those injuries he was paralyzed for
the rest of his life
you did kill him didn't you I mean
there's no damage yeah ultimately you
killed him I understand
but you accept you killed him
I would say yes
John Hinckley uh
in the end people will watch this
interview and they may have already made
their minds up about you we're gonna
have a debate with three people with
different views about this in a moment
but what is your what's your final
message really to viewers who might
remain unconvinced by what they're
hearing and seeing and think actually
you know what he should he should have
stayed in prison if John Lennon's killer
is in prison why is this guy allowed to
to be out
well I would say to anybody who's
listening that
I'm a changed person and I was not just
sitting in prison all these years not
getting treatment I got I've gotten
treatment all these years
and I'm I'm just I don't have the same
thinking that I had back then and I've
shown through the through the freedoms
I've gotten over the past 10 or 15 years
that I do have a good track record of
being a very good law-abiding citizen
John Hinckley Jr I appreciate you
joining me tonight thank you very much
thank you